Selam
[Alkış]
bu gün sizlere
ayarlamışlar de
güzelim benim canım
İnşallah
bu mübarek günde
de iyi oldu ya anlamına
geldim Şimdi nasıl oldu
istiyorum
İstanbul Küçükçekmece
olunca
yaşınızda bir program çok
şimdiki
böyle Geçenlerde yolculuk sevilen
tatlılarımız çiçeğimiz
var ya yapmak gözlerine bakan
çocuk bir şey yani
geliyor
Sana da günaydın Şimdi bu çocuk
[Müzik]
yaşayacağım bana
hiçbir şekilde
verebilirsiniz yapalım gördüm
varmış
olduğumu
bilmiyorsun
aşılıyor Ben
bir
sevmiyorum
başarılı oluyor
köyde taşımalı sistem var orada şehre
girmek bu ve
ilköğretim Tamam görüşürüz görüşürüz İyi
akşamlar
Bir eğlenceli
bir düşünün ve
kendinizi olsun uzaylısın da
pişman eder bu şu
senin Çok yakında her yer bulabilen
sonra görüyorum kıskanıyorum
ablamlara geçiyorum oynuyorum okula
gidemiyorum Allah'ın şişiyor çocuğum
Allah'ın işine uçuyorum ya
böyle geçiyor ve hafif bir görmek yavaş
yapıştırma bile nazlı izleyebilir yanda
değil yavaş yavaş etmesi sağlanıyor
Düşüncelerini de çok ağlıyor erken
Sağ ol yerine
bulamıyorum
bir
sohbet
Tamam oldum
içtiğim
[Müzik]
Bu benim ayrışmasını benim hayatım dönüm
noktası da sayılabilir söyleyeceğim
yaptım
Anne çok iyi
olduğunu alacağınız olacak
Bilmem içerisinde yani
[Müzik]
bilmiyorum
Hadi
yürü ediyorum de yani orjinal zaman
geçiyorsun sanıyordum sanki bölümlerde
çoğunu orada
sana arabayla şey
oldu gözlemle Emine ablama işte bu
ömrümü
yiyeceğim seni
rehberlik araştırma merkezinde
görülebilir sorabilir Üzülme abla
diyorlar
çözüme ulaştırırız böyle bunu yapıyorum
Ve sonra
söyleyebiliriz vardı Annem demiş ki
bizlerin
edebiliriz anne değil bu anlatıyoruz
sonra Tamam çok güzel yıllar
dilerim
insanların geri aldım çok yanından
ayrıldı ve boğazların önemi sevimli var
ona gidip göre Bundan dolayı onlar
tabletle kalem almak gerekiyor Biz
alabiliyor anne severim
gidiyor Her konuda ciddi otobüs
durakları da Evet çok zor sürede gidip
gelen bir sarılayım
birisi vardı olabilir işte ben bunlardan
şey göremeyeceğim Erzurum'da
şarjım bitiyor işte
yanıyor ve ne yapacaksın kişi
böyle görüş yani
tamam
müdürü
benim
annem öyle
olunca da
veriyorlar ve annemin anlatıyor böyle
böyle 18 yaşını geçmiş Normalde
değil
kalmayacak yok ki
kalemini kullanıyorum
Allah Allah
kim ayarladım
Şimdi
[Müzik]
bu
şey şimdi Geçmiş olduğum Kazan bulacağım
öyle biraz daha fazladır
yani sadece oldu bu ne geliyor
çok sorumluluk almışız benim hayatı
kazandı
kazandım the voice Maya sayesinde
bahsedeceğim sonra konuşuyorum Ya anne
oluyorlar diyorum ki oğlum sosyal
hizmetlerin arasında hızında
yorulmayalım işte
Tabii ki her şey
değişik bir şey
yarışmaları bu işte bu spor müsabakaları
anda bizim salaklardan sayesinde
olduğu
için de bu sosyal dediğine katılıyorum
Gerçekten
olarak geldi Çok şeyler geri kalmış
yerlerin ne olduğunu bile bilmeyen
buzdolabında YouTube'a bunu bir ediyorum
geçiririm ver işte
annemi ve çıkmaz o
bastı o kadar da bu kadar tamam
yapacağımız kullanacağım hiçbir şey
diyor Sonra Eve gidiyorum hayatım
geleceği daha önce araçları orada
astroloji aldım Şimdi
86 sınıftaki ilke imza atılacak kadar
oluyorum
sağladık
8 Sen engeli kaldır
bir
açığını kapatma mücadelesiyle
bir şekilde tamamlıyorum boynu
sağlıklarında dönüyorum aynı sınıfta
yenebilirim ama görüyor Ve Yedi yılda
düşündüğümüz için
sanayide Ankara'ya
kadar
ve
üzerinin yağını kendi
şimdi yanım yanım yanım Deniz
yanında değilmişim iyi
geceler Yarın hastaneler görünce
gidiyorum hastaneye zaman çıkıyorum
okula gidiyorum ben de canım öyle
Gerçekten oluyor
[Müzik]
Ben geleyim
mi takımın bir ölüm
bizde ama ben
geri kalmış tıkladım de
adam gerçekten de çok büyük
bizlere
olabilir mi Sen söyle Size
Gel canım düşün boşluğu ve onun kurtuldu
çok hızlandı o gün geldiğinde
de işte şu an değil mi var
sıfırladık
kütüphanenin çalışıyor Bir değilse
bilgisayar
inanılmaz bir noktada
soruyorum geldi ne de sen ne yapıyorsun
bizim okulun bilgisayar işlerim için
işte
istediğiniz
her şeyi çok değil göre gelmesini
bilgisel
olur olan bir iş
Şimdi her şey
ve
[Müzik]
sarıldım şu an gidelim Beğendiyseniz de
içerisinde olabilir anlatmaya çalıştım O
değil de olsa sonuç şimdi vardı bu kadar
verebiliyorlar oynayacağız içerisinde
Deniz o hayata bağlayan çok önemli iki
tane olaylar birisi eğitim bir spor şu
anda bir tane takım sporlarında bir iş
başarmış
sporculardan birisiyim kadını sorun
cumhuriyet tarihi bronz madalya alarak
takım
sporcuları insanın kafasında canlandırır
ama dediniz şimdi ilk madalyayı kazandı
duygularını koyduğumda halinde diğer
canlanıp ya da
şu an alacağınız var orada şu an bir
eğitime kazandım kazandım öğretmeni
sayesinde beden eğitimi öğretmeni
yıllarından beri
gerçekten baya geç kalmış
çok zor uyuyacağım zaman açma O
kim icat edeceğim sizde asla ve asla
yapamam demeyi
ne isterse
veririm
Tamam mı
[Alkış]